Scientists around the world are racing to produce a safe and effective vaccine for the virus that causes COVID-19. Just months after the new coronavirus emerged in China, researchers are testing 40 vaccines in clinical trials in humans and exploring 92 others in pre-clinical studies, according to the New York Times vaccine tracker. But developing an effective vaccine is only part of the battle. Even once one is available, enough people will have to be willing to take it to prevent the spread of the disease. disease, and that may not be easy. An August Gallup poll found deep skepticism among many Americans about a potential COVID-19 vaccine. 35% said they would not take a food and drug administration approved vaccine, even if it were provided to them for free. The numbers were even higher among non-white Americans, 41% of whom would refuse a COVID vaccine, and among Republicans,
世界各地的科学家正竞相为引发新冠肺炎（COVID-19）的病毒研发安全有效的疫苗。根据《纽约时报》的疫苗追踪器显示，在中国出现新型冠状病毒仅几个月后，研究人员正在人类身上进行40种疫苗的临床试验，并在临床前研究中探索另外92种疫苗。但开发出有效的疫苗只是抗疫斗争的一部分。即使疫苗问世，也必须有足够的人愿意接种，才能阻止该疾病的传播，而这并非易事。盖洛普（Gallup）8月份的一项民意调查发现，许多美国人对潜在的新冠疫苗抱有深深的怀疑。35%的人表示，即使免费提供美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）批准的疫苗，他们也不会接种。非白人美国人的这一比例甚至更高，其中41%的人会拒绝接种新冠疫苗；而在共和党人中，
53% of whom said they wouldn't take it either. Psychologists' research can offer insight into why some people forego vaccinations and what policymakers and the health care sector can do to change that. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Gretchen Chapman,
53%的人也表示他们不会接种。心理学家的研究可以让我们深入了解为什么有些人不愿接种疫苗，以及政策制定者和医疗保健行业可以采取哪些措施来改变这种状况。欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是格雷琴·查普曼（Gretchen Chapman）博士，
a cognitive psychologist and professor in the Department of Social and Decision Sciences at Carnegie Mellon University. She studies how people make health decisions, including whether or not to get vaccinated, and how health officials can design interventions that improve vaccine uptake and other healthy behaviors. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Chapman. Thank you so much. The moment ago, I mentioned a recent poll that asked whether people would get a COVID
她是一位认知心理学家，也是卡内基梅隆大学社会与决策科学系的教授。她研究人们如何做出健康决策，包括是否接种疫苗，以及卫生官员如何设计干预措施来提高疫苗接种率和其他健康行为。欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，查普曼博士。非常感谢。刚才我提到了一项最近的民意调查，询问人们是否会接种新冠疫苗，正如我们所知，这种疫苗目前还不存在。所以让我们从一个不太假设性的问题开始。我们每年都已经有流感疫苗了，但不到一半的美国人会去接种。为什么这个比率这么低？这与其他疫苗的比率相比如何？嗯，这是一个我花了很多时间思考的问题。许多疫苗的接种率其实相当高。因此，对于儿童应该接种的所有儿科疫苗，
vaccine, which, as we know, does not yet exist. So let's start with something less hypothetical. We already have a yearly flu vaccine, but less than half of Americans get it. Why is that rate so low? And how does it compare to rates for other vaccines? Well, that is a question that I spend a lot of time thinking about. Vaccination rates for a lot of vaccines are quite high. So for all of the pediatric vaccinations that children are supposed to get,
单独来看，其接种率超过了90%。如果你把所有儿科疫苗作为一个整体来看，大约四分之三的儿童按时接种了所有的疫苗。所以这当然远非理想，但比你刚才引用的流感疫苗的数据要高。因此，流感疫苗以及青少年应该接种的HPV疫苗，是接种率较低、远低于预期接种率的疫苗。原因之一可能是强制接种与非强制接种疫苗之间的差异。因此，学校入学和托儿所等机构都要求接种儿科疫苗。所以，可能是强制规定本身推动了这些
individually, their uptake is more than 90%. if you look at all pediatric vaccinations as a group, something like three quarters of children have had all of their vaccines on time. So that's certainly far from optimal, but higher than the stats you were just quoting for flu shots. So the flu shot and also the HPV vaccination that adolescents are supposed to get, those are the vaccines that have lower, much lower than desired uptake rates. And one reason for that might be the difference between vaccinations that are required versus not required. So pediatric vaccinations are required for school enrollment and daycare and that sort of thing. So it may be the requirement itself that drives those
接种率上升，或者正如学校要求接种这一事实所表明的那样，它们已经变得更加规范化。学校注册并不强制要求接种HPV疫苗。有些地方强制要求接种流感疫苗，比如医院要求其员工接种流感疫苗，但并没有那么广泛地强制要求。所以这可能是流感疫苗接种率较低的部分原因。另一个原因是流感疫苗需要每年接种。所以负担更重。而且我当然对帮助确定哪些人确实去接种流感疫苗的心理学原则非常感兴趣。反疫苗活动人士几十年来一直将腮腺炎、麻疹和风疹（即MMR）疫苗作为目标，并且有很多关于疫苗接种率低的社区爆发麻疹的报道。
rates up or maybe they've just been more normalized as indicated by the fact that schools require them. The HPV vaccine is not required for school registration. The flu shot is required in some places like hospitals were required their personnel to get the flu shot, but it's not as broadly required. So that may be part of the answer for why flu shots have a lower uptake rate. Another reason is that flu shots, you have to get it every year. So there's more of a burden. and I'm certainly very interested in the psychological principles that help to determine which people do get the flu shot. Anti-vaccine activists have targeted the mumps, measles, and rebella, or MMR vaccine for decades, and there have been many reports of measles outbreaks in communities with low vaccination rates.
但你在最近的一篇综述论文中写到，证据实际上表明疫苗拒绝率是稳定的，并没有增加。你能帮我们理清这个看似矛盾的现象吗？是的，这是一个谜。儿童疫苗接种率是稳定的。正如我所说，它们各自都超过了90%。但这还不够高。所以这仍然留下了爆发疫情的空间。那些出于非常强烈的原则性原因反对接种疫苗的人，只是一小群人。
But you wrote in a recent review paper that evidence actually suggests that vaccine refusal rates are stable, not increasing. Can you help square that seeming contradiction? Yeah, that is a puzzle. Pediatric vaccination rates are stable. As I said, they're each individually above 90%. But that's not quite high enough. So that still leaves room for outbreaks. People who have very strongly principled reasons against vaccination, they're a small group.
美国不到1%的儿童根本没有接种任何疫苗。但尽管这是一个小群体，它依然非常重要，部分原因在于地理聚集性。因此，如果许多未接种疫苗的儿童因为父母往往有相似的观点而生活在同一个社区，那么当国际旅行者将麻疹引入该社区时，这个社区就会变得非常脆弱。因此，即使在全国范围内疫苗接种率很高且稳定的情况下，我们也会爆发非常令人担忧的疫情。疫苗是医学史上最伟大的成功故事之一。由于疫苗的存在，天花和脊髓灰质炎等疾病在美国几乎销声匿迹。
Less than 1% of children in the U.S. received no vaccination at all. But even though it's a small group, it's still very important in part because of geographical clustering. So if a lot of unvaccinated children live together in the same community because their parents tend to have similar views, then that makes that community very vulnerable when, say, an international traveler might introduce measles to the community. So we can have very disturbing outbreaks even when nationally speaking, the vaccination rate is high and stable. Vaccines are some of the biggest success stories in the history of medicine. As a result of vaccines, diseases like smallpox and polio are practically unheard of in the United States.
那么，为什么围绕MMR的反疫苗激进分子的信息对某些人如此具有吸引力？是医学界在自我宣传方面做得不好吗？嗯，当然，人们没有做所有他们应该做的事情来保持健康，这是一个非常普遍的问题，并不局限于接种疫苗。我们很多人在不该抽烟的时候抽烟。我们锻炼不够。我们吃太多糖而且超重。我们没有一直系好安全带。因此，人们没有按照建议的比率接种疫苗，只是关于保持高度一致的健康行为有多难的更宏观画面的一部分。如果你从外行人的角度来看待疫苗接种，我们要求人们做的事其实是一种相当奇怪的行为。在这里，我们要把这种引起危险传染病的病毒拿来，但别担心，我们已经对其进行了改良或灭活，所以它不会致病，然后我们要把它注射到你婴儿的手臂里。你看，如果你不了解疫苗背后的证据，这听起来会像是医疗专业人员对你提出的一个非常奇怪的要求。因此，这或许并不令人意外，
So why are the anti-vaccine activist messages around MMR so compelling to some people? Is medicine doing a poor job of promoting itself? Well, certainly the fact that people don't do everything they should do to stay healthy, that is a very general problem that's not concentrated on vaccination. So many of us smoke when we shouldn't. We don't exercise enough. We eat too much sugar and we're overweight. We don't wear seatbelts all the time. So the fact that people don't vaccinate at the rates that would be recommended is just part of a broader picture of how hard it is to.
有些人认为疫苗是可怕的。你必须对科学证据有所了解，并信任向你介绍这些证据的医疗服务提供者，才能相信疫苗带来的巨大健康益处。嗯，这难道不正说明了我刚才提出的问题吗？即医学界在向人们解释疫苗方面做得还不够好。有很多证据表明，当初让人们对像MMR这样的疫苗产生种种疑虑和激动情绪的，是《柳叶刀》杂志上发表的一篇现已被推翻的论文，然而至今似乎仍无法消除那个糟糕的故事。是的，不，我认为这是一个极好的观点。
promote very consistent health behavior. If you think about vaccinations from a layperson perspective, it is a pretty bizarre behavior that we are asking people to do. So here we're going to take this virus that causes a dangerous infectious disease, but don't worry, we've modified it or killed it so it can't cause the disease, and then we're going to inject it into your baby's arm. Like, if you don't know about the evidence behind vaccines, that would sound like a very bizarre request that medical professionals are making of you. So it's perhaps not surprising that
我想我会扩展你的观点，并指出这种现象并非疫苗所独有。因此，在推广许多健康行为方面，医学界并没有达到我们希望的成功程度，不仅仅是疫苗接种。阴谋论和错误信息对公众健康构成了危险，但这些危险并不局限于疫苗接种的世界。它们发生在许多领域。错误信念和不健康行为背后的心理学建立在一套广泛而深远的原则基础之上，要克服这些原则并非易事。在我刚才提到的那篇综述论文中，你研究了关于提高疫苗接种率的干预措施的研究。你发现了什么？什么有效？我们考虑了三类干预措施。第一类是旨在改变人们对疫苗接种的信念和感受的干预措施。比如提供信息。第二类是社会因素。比如告知人们其他人在做什么，
some people think of vaccines as scary. You have to know a little bit about the scientific evidence and trust the providers that are telling you about that evidence to buy into the drastic health benefits that vaccinations are offering. Well, doesn't that speak to my question that medicine is not doing that good a job of explaining vaccines to people. There's a lot of evidence out there that what got people all exercised over vaccines like MMR, for example, was a now discredited paper published in the Lancet, and yet still there seems to be no way to kill that bad story. Yeah, no, I think that's an excellent point.
或者告知人们疫苗接种的亲社会益处。第三类我们称之为直接干预行为。也就是说，不是试图改变人们的想法和感受，而是努力让接种疫苗的行为变得更容易参与。正是在这第三类干预措施中，拥有大量支持此类干预措施有效性的证据。提供信息在改变行为的能力方面，其成效记录可以说是出人意料地参差不齐。社会因素非常有前景，并且有大量的社会心理学证据支持它们，但其中大部分证据尚未在疫苗接种领域得到证实。所以它必须成为一种标准做法，让你获得预约，并被告知你必须去接种疫苗。是的，标准做法，我认为这是一个很好的短语，可以用来总结那一类干预措施。因此，来自医师的推荐，特别是我们所说的推定推荐（即医师说：你今天该接种这种疫苗了。所以我们会在面诊结束时为你接种），这传达出这是一种标准做法。这是正常的。这不是什么可以争论的事情。默认设置，比如预先安排疫苗接种预约、激励措施、提醒、强制规定，这些类型的事物。
I guess I would expand on your point and suggest that this phenomenon is not specific to vaccines. So medicine has not been as successful as we would have. like at promoting a lot of healthy behaviors, not just vaccination. Conspiracy theories and misinformation are dangerous to public health, but those dangers don't just rest in the world of vaccination. They occur in a lot of domains. And the psychology behind false beliefs and unhealthy behavior are rests on a broad and far-ranging
我们正在等待的新冠疫苗。一方面，有些人可能会特别有动力去接种，以便恢复正常生活。但另一方面，由于人们认为它是仓促推出的，许多其他人对安全性感到特别担忧。这是否改变了卫生官员在公众信息传递方面需要做的事情？我想可能会，是的。所以我之前提到过，信息干预措施试图改变人们对疫苗的看法，但它们的成效记录并不一致。如果你仔细想想，你上一次仅仅因为了解了一个简短的事实而改变行为是什么时候？你知道的，你是一个锻炼不够的人，然后有人给你一个小册子，突然之间你就开始充分锻炼了。这看起来很不现实，而且关于疫苗安全性和有效性的简短信息能够让一个从不费心去打流感疫苗的人变成一个每年都打流感疫苗的人，这似乎也很不现实。
set of principles that are not trivial to overcome. In that same review paper I mentioned a few moments ago, you examined the research on interventions to increase vaccination rates. What did you find? What works? We considered three categories of interventions. The first was interventions designed to change people's beliefs and feelings about vaccination. So things like providing information. The second was social factors. So things like informing people about what everyone else is doing.
但这些信息传递面临如此大阻力的部分原因在于，人们对流感疫苗已经了解很多了。他们可能年复一年地经历过：尽管我从来不打疫苗，但我从不感冒。所以这能有多大用处呢？或者我有一群朋友告诉我疫苗是有风险的。所以我已经仔细考虑过了。因此，一条简短的信息不太可能大幅改变他们的信仰。
or about the pro-social benefits of vaccination. And the third category we called intervening on behavior directly. So not trying to change what people think and feel, like just trying to make the vaccination behavior, the easier behavior to engage in. And it was that third category where there's the bulk of the evidence supporting the efficacy of those kind of interventions. Providing information is sort of surprisingly has a mixed track record in terms of of its ability to change behavior. And the social factors are very promising, and there's a lot of
但对于新冠病毒，我们对这种疫苗还一无所知。所以这种情况下的信息干预实际上可能会对人们的信念产生影响，进而影响他们的行为，因为我们算是在一个没有任何信息的起点上开始的。因此，准确传诚这种新疫苗的安全性和有效性，并且诚实地传达这一点，我认为真的非常重要。如果说有什么时候信息干预能够对人们的行为产生影响，那可能就是现在。
social psychology evidence supporting them, but not much of that evidence has been documented in the realm of vaccination yet. So it has to become a standard practice so that you're given an appointment and you're just told that you have to get your vaccination. Yes, standard practice, I think, is a good phrase to sort of summarize that category. So recommendations from physicians, especially what we call presumptive recommendations where the physician says, you're due for this vaccination today. So we'll be giving it at the end of the session, which communicates that it's standard practice. It's normal. It's not something to be debated. Defaults, so things like pre-scheduling an appointment for vaccination, incentives, reminders, requirements, those sorts of practices.
因此，关于流感，我从很多人那里听到的是：“啊，这只是流感。没有人会死于流感。”但事实并非如此。人们一直在死于流感。但人们有一种感觉，觉得这没什么大不了的。而且我们有一个政府告诉我们新冠肺炎没什么大不了的，尽管我们看到人们戴着呼吸机，还有人在医院里一住就是好几个星期。有可能通过吓唬人们来让他们去接种疫苗吗？
The COVID vaccine we're waiting for. On the one hand, some people may be especially motivated to take it to get back to normal. But on the other hand, many others are especially worried about safety because of the perception that it's being rushed. Does that change what health officials need to do in terms of public messaging? I think it might, yes. So I mentioned earlier that interventions, informational interventions, they try to change what people think about the vaccination, have. an inconsistent track record. If you think about it, when was the last time that just learning one short fact changed your behavior? You know, you're someone who doesn't exercise enough and then someone gives you a little brochure and all of a sudden you're exercising enough. Like that seems pretty unrealistic and it also might seem unrealistic that a short message about the safety and efficacy of vaccination would change someone who never bothered to get a flu shot into someone who gets one every year.
健康心理学中有很多关于恐惧信息的文献。有时恐惧信息是有效的，但它们也可能适得其反，产生“鸵鸟效应”，即人们倾向于躲避可怕的信息，而不是采取行动来对抗威胁。恐惧信息似乎在促进不行动方面效果更好。所以如果你想让人们呆在家里不出门，恐惧信息可能会相当有效，但如果你试图促进诸如接种疫苗之类的行动，它们可能会适得其反，除非你为人们提供了一条清晰的行动路线。因此，如果人们确切知道在哪里以及何时能，
But part of the reason why those information messages are such an uphill battle is because people already know a lot about the flu shot. They've maybe experienced that year after year I never get the flu, even though I never get the vaccine. So how useful could it be? Or I have this group of friends that tells me vaccinations are risky. And so I've thought about it a lot. And so a short information message is unlikely to make a big change in their beliefs.
够接种疫苗，并且相信它是安全的，文献表明，这才是恐惧信息能够发挥作用的时候。我们一直试图开发一种针对艾滋病毒的疫苗，但30多年来一直没有成功，最初的流感疫苗花了大约八年的时间才开发出来。科学界曾经开发出像政府所承诺的那样迅速的疫苗吗？疫苗开发其实并不是我的专业领域。我想我读到过，腮腺炎疫苗是有史以来开发速度最快的疫苗，花费了四年的时间。所以你完全说得对，快速开发疫苗是一种罕见现象。当然，对疫苗系统的信任，包括生产和分销，是至关重要的。
But with COVID, we don't know anything about that vaccine yet. So this is a situation where an information intervention might actually have an influence on people's belief and then their behavior because we're sort of starting from a starting point of no information. So communicating exactly how safe and effective the new vaccine is and communicating that, honestly, I think is really important. And if there's ever a time when an information intervention is going to impact people's behavior, this might be it.
关于疫苗信心有很多研究，对疫苗提供者和开发者的信任是其中的一部分。因此，通过“曲速行动”（Operation Warp Speed）以极快速度推出新冠疫苗，我们面临的一个真正风险是，我们可能会削弱公众对疫苗系统的一些信任。是的，我想我们刚才已经讨论过这一点了，通过我刚才提到的盖洛普民意调查，该调查发现某些群体可能特别不愿意接受疫苗，例如非白人美国人和共和党人。与不同群体沟通时，是否需要不同的信息和策略？也许吧。我们知道，来自医疗保健提供者的推荐与疫苗接种率密切相关，甚至有一些实验对患者进行了随机分组。他们收到了不同种类的推荐。所以我们知道，推荐对疫苗接种率甚至具有因果影响。不过，非常有可能是，
So with the flu, what I hear from a lot of people is, ah, it's just the flu. Nobody dies from the flu. But that's not true. People die from the flu all the time. But there's this sense that it isn't a big deal. And we have an administration that is telling us that COVID isn't a big deal, even though we're seeing people on ventilators and folks who are in the hospital for weeks and weeks. Is it possible to scare people into getting a vaccine?
对于那些对医疗系统已经抱有高度信任的人来说，医生的推荐将是最有效的；因此，有历史原因对医疗系统信任度较低的有色人种，其行为可能受医生推荐的影响较小；对整体科学信任度较低的保守派，受医生推荐的影响也可能较小。因此，那里可能需要对信息进行一些定制。我还想提一下社会规范的概念，即这样一种效应：我们喜欢做与我们相似的其他人在做的事情。从这个意义上说，如果我们看到其他像我们一样的人去接种疫苗，我们就会认为“哦，这就是像我这样的人会做的事”，我们会信任大众的智慧。社会心理学表明，近端规范或规范，即在我所处的特定情境中，其他像我一样的人在做什么。
There's a lot of literature in health psychology on fear messages. And sometimes fear messages are effective, but they can also backfire and produce an ostrich effect where the person wants to hide from the fearful information rather than taking action against the threat. Fear messages seem to work better to promote inaction. So if you want people to stay in their houses and not go out, a fear message might be pretty effective, but if you're trying to promote action like getting a vaccine, they may backfire unless you have a clear route of action for people. So if people know exactly where and when,
这些才是最具影响力的规范。因此，如果是有色人种看到他们所在社区的其他人以高接种率接种疫苗，或者如果保守派看到其他保守派以高接种率接种疫苗，那将是很有影响力的，但这些规范必须针对我们试图接触的社区具有针对性。我听说有人建议，一旦有了新冠肺炎疫苗，就应该把它与季节性流感疫苗结合起来接种。你认为这是一个好主意吗？你认为这会使人们更有可能同时接种这两种疫苗，从而提高流感疫苗的接种率吗？
they could get the vaccine and they trust that it's safe, that's when the fear message could be effective, the literature indicates. We've been trying unsuccessfully to develop a vaccine for HIV for more than 30 years, and the original flu vaccine took something like eight years to develop, Has science ever created a vaccine as quickly as the administration is promising? Vaccine development is actually not my area of expertise. I think I read that the mumps vaccine was the quickest vaccine ever to be developed and that it took four years. So you're absolutely correct that quick vaccination development is an oddity. And of course, trust in the vaccination system, both production and distribution is critical.
当然，便利性是疫苗接种中的一个大因素。因此，想想那些24/7全天候营业并提供流感疫苗和其他一些疫苗的药店，而不是必须预约去看医生，或者提供免费现场疫苗接种的工作场所。这种便利性确实会提高接种率。将流感疫苗与新的一剂新冠疫苗捆绑在一起将是便利性的另一个例子。当然，那些原本就打算接种流感疫苗的人更有可能在那个时候接种新冠疫苗，因为这很方便。而且很有可能，
There's a lot of research on vaccine confidence and trust in the providers and developers of vaccines is part of that. So a real risk that we are facing with Operation Warp Speed to get a very fast COVID vaccine is we may undermine some of that trust in the vaccination system. Yeah, I think we've been talking about that a little bit with the Gallup poll that I mentioned a little while ago that found some groups maybe particularly reluctant to. accept the vaccine, non-white Americans and Republicans, for example, will different messages and strategies be necessary for communicating with different groups? Perhaps. We know that recommendations from health care providers are strongly associated with vaccine uptake, and there are even some experiments that randomize patients. They get different kinds of recommendations. So we know that recommendations have even a causal impact on vaccine uptake. It's very possible, though, that
正如你所建议的那样，情况会反过来：那些对接种新型新冠疫苗充满热情，但从未真正费心去打流感疫苗的人，现在会因为它们被捆绑在一起而两者都接种。我不确定这是否能吸引那些对注射任何一种疫苗都感到犹豫不决的人。我知道这还为时过早，也许这不是一个公平的问题，但我们是否有任何理由相信新冠肺炎疫苗会比季节性流感疫苗（效果其实不太好）更有效呢？我认为这还有待分晓。你说得对，季节性流感疫苗确实不太好。我读到过其有效性在60%到80%的范围内，这意味着它将你的风险降低了60%，或者降至如果没有疫苗时你风险的40%。
physician recommendations would be most effective for people who already have high trust in the medical system. So people of color who have historical reasons to have less trust in the medical system might, their behavior might be less influenced by physician recommendations, conservatives who have less trust in science overall may be less influenced by physician recommendation. So there might be some customizing of messages there. I'd also like to mention the idea of social norms, this effect that we like to do what other people like us are doing. We sort of trust in the wisdom of the crowds in that sense if we see other people like us getting vaccinated, then we think, oh, that's what people like me do. And social psychology shows that proximal norms or norms, what other people are what other people like me are doing in the very situation than I am in.
然而，接种它仍然是值得的，因为很显然，某种程度的风险降低总比没有好，而且也是因为群体免疫的动态机制，即使它对所有接种的人不都有效，但如果它对足够多的人有效，那么在社区中传播疫苗（此处原文如此，指病毒）的携带者就会减少。因此，按照同样的逻辑，即使是一种远非完美的冠状病毒疫苗，推广起来也仍然非常值得。在疫苗问世之前，保持社交距离、戴口罩和勤洗手等预防策略基本上是我们所拥有的全部手段，
Those are the norms that are most influential. So if people of color see other people from their same communities getting vaccinated in high rates or if conservatives see other conservatives getting vaccinated in high rates, that's going to be influential, but those norms have to be specific to the communities that we're trying to reach. I've heard suggestions that once there's a COVID-19 vaccine, that it be coupled with the seasonal flu vaccine. Do you think that's a good idea? Do you believe it would make people more likely to get both? and thus increase the uptake of the flu vaccine?
来控制新冠病毒。早在5月，你就为《对话》（The Conversation）杂志写过一篇文章，探讨了美国人对这些措施感到厌倦，并且从心理学角度来看，这并不令人意外。现在几个月过去了，人们比5月时更加厌倦了。心理学研究告诉我们，为什么会这样？我们怎样才能保持人们继续采取这些措施的动力呢？嗯，你不需要心理学科学。你只需要日常经验就能告诉你，持久的健康行为改变确实具有极大的挑战性。因此，即使是戒烟也非常非常困难，即便如此，成功戒烟的人也经常复吸。减肥，难得难以置信。然而成功减肥的人
Certainly convenience is a big factor in vaccination. So think of pharmacies that are open 24-7 and offer flu shots and some other vaccinations as opposed to having to make an appointment to see your doctor or workplaces that offer free on-site vaccinations. That kind of convenience does increase uptake. And bundling the flu shot with the new COVID vaccine would be another example. of convenience. Certainly people who are already planning on getting the flu shot would be more likely to get the COVID vaccine at that point because it's convenient. And it's possible,
往往会反弹。因此，健康行为很难开始，要维持下去就更难了。所以没有简单的答案。有些行为最终会变成习惯，比如，我不知道，刷牙对很多人来说可能就是一个好例子，他们几十年来一直保持着这种行为。有助于持久行为改变的一个心理学原则是，如果这种行为能带来即时益处或即时回报。所以刷牙可能是一个好例子：你的口腔里会有一种干净清爽薄荷味的感觉，这就是除了预防蛀牙的长期益处之外的即时回报。
as you suggested, it would go the other way that people who are enthusiastic about getting the new COVID vaccine, but never really bothered with the flu shot, will now get both because they're bundled. I'm not sure that would bring along folks who are reluctant to get either vaccine. I know it's preliminary, and maybe this isn't a fair question, but do we have to be have any reason to believe that a COVID-19 vaccine will be any more effective than the seasonal flu vaccine, which isn't very good? I think the jury's still out on that. You're right that the seasonal flu vaccine is not very good. I've read that effectiveness is in the 60 to 80 percent range, meaning that it reduces your risk by 60 percent or down to 40 percent of what your risk
然而，戴口罩或保持社交距离，要设计出一种在当下感觉良好的短期回报是相当困难的。对某些人来说，锻炼的方式就是这样。有些人真的很享受运动的感觉，或者跑步结束时获得的那种内啡肽冲动。所以这让他们能够坚持下去。因此，在我们可以建立这些即时回报或行为的实际享受程度的范围内，这将使它长期持续下去。对于某些行为来说，这确实极具挑战性。
would have been without the vaccine. It's still worth getting, however, because obviously some risk reduction is better than others, and also because of the dynamics of herd immunity, that even if it's not effective in everyone who gets it, if it's effective in enough people, then there are fewer carriers to spread the vaccine around the community. So by the same logic, even a far-from-perfect COVID vaccine could still be very worthwhile to roll out. Until a vaccine is available, prevent the strategies such as physical distancing, mask wearing, and hand-washing are pretty much all we have.
那么我们是否应该考虑付钱让人们去接种新冠疫苗？有点像献血时你会得到20美元那样。有证据表明，付费让人们去打流感疫苗可以提高接种率。所以这不是一个坏主意。要扩大规模很困难。你知道，如果你想让3亿人接种疫苗，
to keep COVID in check. You wrote an article for the conversation back in May about how Americans already retiring of these measures and that from a psychological perspective, that wasn't surprising. Now here we are months later and people are even more tired of it than they were in May. What does psychological research tell us about why that is? And how can we keep people motivated to continue taking these measures? Well, you don't need psychological science. You only need everyday experience to tell you that lasting health behavior change is really challenging. So even quitting smoking is very, very difficult, but even so, people who are successful at quitting smoking, they often relapse. Losing weight, incredibly difficult. And yet people who are successful
而你打算每个人付他们5美元，加在一起这就是一大笔钱。然后我们还担心下游效应。所以我们还不知道新冠疫苗是一劳永逸的疫苗，还是更像是流感疫苗那样每年都必须接种。所以如果我们今年付给你5美元，然后那个激励计划被取消了，而我们明年不付给你5美元，你明年是不是可能更不愿意去接种疫苗了，因为你会想：“我的5美元呢？”你现在正在进行任何与新冠疫苗相关的研究吗？你认为这项工作的下一个前沿是什么？我正在与我在卡内基梅隆大学的同事朱莉·唐斯（Julie Downs）和斯蒂芬·布鲁梅尔（Stephen Broomell）合作开展一个与新冠相关的项目。我们有一个国家科学基金会（NSF）资助的项目。我们在3月和4月进行了一项基线调查，研究了人们对社交距离和个人卫生（如洗手和戴口罩）自我报告的一些相关因素。
in losing weight frequently regain the weight. So health behaviors are hard to get started and they're even harder to keep going. So there's no easy answer to that. some behaviors do end up being habitual like i don't know brushing teeth is probably a good example for a lot of people they maintain that behavior for decades and decades one psychological principle that helps with lasting behavior change is if there is an immediate benefit or an immediate reward to the behavior so maybe brushing keith is a good example you get that sort of clean minty feeling in your mouth, that's the immediate reward in addition to the long-term benefit of preventing cavities.
我们发现了一些在很多行为中都会出现的传统结果，即人们认为行为的有效性与参与该行为密切相关，他们的担忧和可能性风险判断与参与这些行为相关，还有他们感知的社会规范（例如，如果他们认为其他很多人都在戴口罩，他们就更有可能说自己也在戴口罩）。我们还发现了其他一些研究发现过的结果，那就是巨大的党派分歧。因此，支持当前的白宫行政当局、变得更加保守或更加共和党化、认为大流行被夸大了。这些都与较低的预防行为呈负面相关。
Whereas wearing a mask or socially distancing, it's sort of hard to engineer what would be a short-term reward that it sort of feels good in the moment. Exercise that works the way for some people. Some people just really enjoy the feeling of exercise or that sort of endorphin rush that they get at the end of a run. And so that keeps them going. So to the extent that we can build in those immediate rewards or actual enjoyability of the behavior, that's going to keep it going long term. And that's just very challenging for some behaviors.
然后，我们一直在试行一些不同的信息干预措施，以看看它们是否会影响佩戴口罩的意愿。我们已经进行了相当多的试点研究，并且我们认为我们设计的干预措施是基于良好的心理学理论和文献的。但到目前为止，这些干预措施都没有改变人们佩戴口罩的意愿。你们尝试了什么？我们尝试了社会规范操纵。曾有一项民意调查显示，大约87%的美国人至少在部分时间佩戴口罩，而且在自由派和保守派之间其实相当一致。所以我们将这个事实告诉了人们，而另一些人则没有被告知这个事实。
So should we consider paying people to get the COVID vaccine and kind of like when you donate blood, you get 20 bucks? There is evidence that paying people to get a flu shot increases uptake. So that's not a bad idea. It's difficult to scale. You know, if you want to get 300 million people vaccinated. and you're going to pay them each $5, that's like a lot of money put all together. And then we also worry about the downstream effects. So we don't know yet whether the COVID vaccine is going to be a sort of once-in-a-lifetime vaccine or more like the flu shot where you have to get it every year. So if we pay you $5 this year and then that incentive program is discontinued and we're
这没有任何影响，可能是因为他们所要做的就是走出门外，看看他们社区里的人实际在做什么。所以我们的消息与他们关于社会规范的经验证据相比简直不值一提。我们在德克萨斯州州长发布口罩令后不久，向他们告知了一些口罩令。我们要么告诉他们那个强制令，要么告诉他们加利福尼亚州的强制令。我们认为告诉他们德克萨斯州的强制令会更有影响力，因为人们会想：哦，好吧，如果连德克萨斯州这样的红州都强制要求戴口罩，那戴口罩一定相当重要。但这并没有产生影响。我们尝试了一个可识别受害者的操纵手段，向他们提供了一个来自媒体的真实故事，一个关于因新冠肺炎去世的年轻健康大学生的悲伤故事，
not paying you $5 next year, would you maybe be less likely to get vaccinated less year because you're like, where's my $5? Are you doing any COVID vaccine-related research right now? What do you think is the next horizon for this work? I am working on a COVID-related project with my colleagues at Carnegie Mellon University, Julie Downs and Stephen Broomell. We have an NSF-funded project. We did a baseline survey back in March and April where we looked at some correlates of people's self-report about social distancing and personal hygiene like handwashing. and mask wearing. We found some sort of traditional results that are found in a, for a lot of behaviors that people's perceived effectiveness of the behaviors was strongly
心想这太令人惊讶和悲伤了，你会有动力去戴口罩以防止其他人被感染，但这并没有影响他们的口罩意愿。所以这些调查有许多其他调查所具有的局限性，比如样本量适中，我们测量的不是真实行为而只是意愿，以及存在社会赞许性，人们可能认为一个研究新冠肺炎行为的研究人员可能希望你戴口罩。因此，人们可能会感到有压力，即使他们并不真的打算这样做，也会说他们打算戴口罩，这可能会掩盖效果。因此，我们可能在这些调查中看不到效果有很多原因。但当然，
correlated with engaging in the behavior, that their worry and likelihood risk judgments were correlated with engaging in the behaviors and also that their perceived social norms, if they thought lots of other people were wearing masks, for example, they would be more likely to say that they were wearing masks. We also found what some other studies have found, which is a big partisan divide. So support for the current White House administration being more conservative or more Republican, thinking that the pandemic has been overblown. These were all correlated with lower preventive behaviors.
在调查中看到效果对于能够改变实际行为的干预措施来说将是令人鼓舞的。好吧，谢谢你今天加入我们，查普曼博士。这真的很有趣。我很享受与你交谈。哦，我也很高兴能与你交谈。谢谢。你可以在我们的网站 www.apa.org 上找到《心理学谈话》过往的节目，也可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听。如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，请给我们发电子邮件，邮箱是 speaking of psychology @ apa.org。那是 speaking of psychology，全部连在一起，在 apa.org。
We've then been piloting some different message interventions to see if they might affect intentions to wear masks. And we've run quite a handful of pilot studies and are, we think the interventions that we designed were based on good psychological theory and literature. But so far, none of those interventions have changed people's intentions to wear masks. What did you try? We tried a social norm manipulation. There was a poll that had come out that said something like 87% of Americans were wearing masks, at least some of the time, and then it was actually pretty consistent between liberals and conservatives. So we told people that fact versus didn't tell them that fact.
《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理协会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。
That had no influence, perhaps because all they have to do is walk outside their door and see what people in their neighborhood are actually doing. So our message may be pale to comparison to their experiential evidence of social norms. We told them about some mask mandates shortly after the Texas governor issued a mask mandate. We either told them about that mandate or the California mandate. We thought that telling them about the Texas mandate would be more influential because people would think like, oh, well, if even red states like Texas are requiring masks, it must be pretty important to wear a mask that did not have an influence. We tried an identifiable victim manipulation where we gave him a real story from the media, a sad story about a young, healthy college student who died from COVID.
这没有任何影响，也许是因为他们只需出门看一看邻居们实际在做什么。因此，与他们对社会规范的切身体验相比，我们的信息可能显得苍白无力。我们在德克萨斯州州长颁布口罩令后不久，向他们告知了一些口罩令。我们要么告诉他们这个命令，要么告诉他们加利福尼亚州的命令。我们认为，告诉他们德克萨斯州的命令会更有影响力，因为人们会想，哦，好吧，如果连德克萨斯州这样的红色州都要求戴口罩，那戴口罩一定非常重要，但这并没有产生影响。我们尝试了一种具象受害者的操纵方法，向他们提供了一个来自媒体的真实故事，这是一个关于一名死于新冠肺炎的年轻、健康的大学生的悲伤故事。
thinking that that's like so surprising and sad, you would be motivated to wear a mask to prevent other people from being infected, but that did not influence their masks intentions. So these surveys have lots of limitations that other surveys have like a modest sample size and the fact that we're not measuring real behavior, we're only measuring intentions, and that there's social desirability that people probably figure out that a researcher who's studying COVID behaviors probably wants you to wear a mask. And so people may feel pressure to say that they intend to wear a mask even if they're not really intending and that may obscure effects. So there's many reasons why we might not see an effect in these surveys. But of course,
人们会觉得这非常令人惊讶和悲伤，你会因此有动力去戴口罩以防止其他人被感染，但这并没有影响他们的戴口罩意愿。因此，这些调查存在许多其他调查所具有的局限性，比如样本量适中，我们没有测量实际行为而只测量了意愿，以及存在社会赞许性效应——研究新冠行为的研究人员可能希望你戴口罩，这一点人们大概能猜到。因此，人们可能会感到压力，即使他们并非真的打算戴口罩，也会说他们打算戴口罩，这可能会掩盖实际效果。因此，我们可能在这些调查中看不到效果有很多原因。但当然，
seeing an effect in a survey would have been encouraging in terms of an intervention that could work to change actual behavior. Well, thank you for joining us today, Dr. Chapman. It's been really interesting. I enjoyed talking with you. Oh, I was delighted to talk with you as well. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org.
在调查中看到效果本来会令人鼓舞，因为它表明某种干预措施可能对改变实际行为有效。好的，谢谢您今天来到我们的节目，查普曼博士。这真的非常有趣。我很享受与您的交谈。哦，我也很高兴能与您交谈。谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 www.apa.org 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》往期的节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，请给我们发电子邮件：speaking of psychology at APA.org。即 Speaking of Psychology（连在一起），at APA.org。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学对话》由莉·威纳曼制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·康迪汉。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。